[Musica]
libris 1 nigris e dico libris perché
libri sa è più della semplice arroganza
è la spinta a superare i propri limiti a
migliorare se stessi ad avvicinarsi agli
dei ed è per questo che gli dei
l'hanno sempre punita oggi gli dei sono
un po più tolleranti però libri non gode
di migliore fortuna perché diciamocelo
quando quei vincenti arroganti visionari
falliscono noi godiamo
tranquilli non si tratta di essere
persone orribili è un'emozione ed è
assolutamente naturale si chiama
schadenfreude la parola viene dal
tedesco shade disgrazia freud e gioia ed
è l'altro lato della medaglia testa i
brief croce schadenfreude ma cominciamo
un attimo da libri per avere un filo
logico
molti di voi conosceranno beh poi dopo
oggi sicuramente tutti nella storia di
edipo il re greco noto per essere stato
per anni il testimonial ufficiale della
psicanalisi ora edipo pecca di idris non
nella parte in cui gioca al dottore con
la mamma quello non era colpa sua non lo
sapeva
lui perché libris perché vuole vedere
quello che un mortale non dovrebbe poter
vedere alla fine ce la fa e la sua
punizione un contrappasso di vino è
l'accecamento poi c'è un'altra storia di
brees meno nota il protagonista è un
panchinaro della mitologia greca
tale capaneo che però viene ripreso
anche da dante nell'inferno capaneo per
primo riesce a scalare le mura di [ __ ]
era teme arriva sulle mura e invece di
dedicarsi a conquistare la città come
farebbe un qualsiasi eroe normale
ha un'idea migliore lui sale sul
torrione più alto e bestemmia no non
bestemmio zoomorfe sarebbe più
divertente ma la sua bestemmia è di
gridare che lui è superiore agli uomini
e anche agli dei che l'idea talmente
forte che zeus che si stava facendo un
po gli affari suoi leggeva la gazzetta
lo sente e non gradisce decide di
spiegargli una o due cosette e per non
saper né leggere né scrivere lo fulmina
io me la immagino la scena è fantastica
stupirla superiore ma vieni usa si
sbaglia una cosa fantastica è bellissima
però io vengo dal mondo della psicologia
non mi occupo delle reazioni degli dei
ma delle persone e sono sicuro che
moltissimi di voi
sentendo la storia di capaneo avranno
pensato che gli sta anche bene è normale
che lo penso anch'io
edipo e capaneo hanno lo stesso peccato
però il primo akira pietà ed empatia
il secondo schadenfreude in teoria
certo se avete un bidone dell'immondizia
al posto del cuore allora godete per
qualsiasi disgrazia ma questa è un'altra
storia
il punto è che da psicologo lasciate in
freud e può essere prevista ed evitata
ora un fallimento per attivare la
schadenfreude deve avere due
caratteristiche primo deve essere
clamoroso
bisogna fallire quando si è più esposti
meglio ancora se dopo che ci si è
vantati in questo capaneo è
assolutamente imbattibile
la seconda è che bisogna fallire dove si
è più forti questa è un po più
sofisticata mi faccio un esempio ci sono
un italiano un olandese e un tedesco non
è una barzelletta un esperimento
scientifico
l'olandese vede su un monitor 2 scenette
nella prima c'è un tedesco un attore che
gli dicono essere tedesco che fa un
colloquio di lavoro e fallisce nella
seconda c'è un italiano che fa un
colloquio di lavoro e fallisce lasciate
freud dell'olandese e diretta solo al
tedesco la spiegazione è semplice perché
nello stereotipo dell'olandese
l'italiano è forte dal punto di vista
relazionale ma il tedesco è quello forte
sul lavoro quindi dovrebbe farcela
quando fallisce scatta la chanel freud
il corollario è un po infelice perché
significa che si può avere schadenfreude
non soltanto per un oggettiva i brees
individuale ma anche solo per
l'appartenenza a dei gruppi che hanno
associati degli stereotipi
ora gli ho raccontato questa cosa
magari bello magari interessante e voi
potreste dirmi è a me che cosa mi cambia
ma cambia solo una cosa tutto no la
apple risponderebbe così ma loro sono
intensi in realtà è utile conoscere
lasciata in freud e perché lasciate in
freud e influenza i nostri pensieri e le
nostre azioni
anche in politica ora uno studio
americano mostra che esiste una tendenza
a godere
quando un paese va a rotoli enel
è un paese va a rotoli e al governo c'è
un partito che non ci piace
ora la situazione fin qua ci sta il
problema è che se noi godiamo alcuni di
noi possono essere tentati a non agire
per evitare il tracollo collettivo e
questo ci interessa un po tutti
un secondo incrocio tra schadenfreude e
politica è quando un fallimento
clamoroso diventa l'unico metro di
giudizio per valutare un'azione di
governo ora recentemente c'è stato un
referendum
forse ve lo ricordate ora è difficile
che un singolo evento in cinque anni sia
l'unico metro per valutare una persona o
un azione nel bene e nel male ma
quell'evento e soprattutto la carica di
personalizzazione che si era attivata
rispetto a quell'evento ha portato a
evaporazione di milioni di voti ora i
brief schadenfreude immigrazione emotiva
di voti è quello che si chiama voto di
pancia ma lasciamo stare un secondo la
politica in quale altro ambito ci può
interessare direttamente la sharan freud
la vita quotidiana tutti noi ne siamo
potenzialmente esposti e non è bello a
tirarsi la gioia degli altri quando si
fallisce
per questo io vi darò tre modalità per
difendervi da lasciare in florida in un
lavoro da psicologo sono qui per questo
primo identificate
dove siete forti la questione è
abbastanza semplice
in quel caso bisogna mantenere alta la
componente di umiltà perché l'umiltà è
la nostra assicurazione sul fallimento
libris lasciatela possibilmente per gli
ambiti in cui non c'è grande attesa
i riflettori sono spenti perché poi si
accenderanno e l'effetto sarà ancora più
forte
seconda cosa sfuggito gli stereotipi
ora se io volessi fare lo stereotipo
dell'italiano mi metterei su una coppola
prenderei un mandolino gli italiani
suonano il mandolino e canterei italiano
ovvero di toto cutugno sarebbe uno show
abbastanza orrendo quindi velo risparmio
il punto è che nella vostra testa io
avrei i lati positivi e i lati negativi
dell'idea di italiano che ciascuno di
voi è in testa e magari questi tratti
non mi rispecchiano per niente se invece
però io creo un'identità inedita
prendendo il buono da tutti i gruppi di
cui faccio parte e delle persone che ho
avuto la fortuna di incontrare allora io
avrò curiosità non pregiudizio capito la
differenza
il terzo trucco è molto semplice ma poco
praticato apritevi comunicate se le
persone potranno conoscere per quello
che siete veramente allora nei loro
occhi non ci sarà più la voglia di
vedermi fallire saranno lì per darvi una
mano perché conosceranno le vostre
motivazioni i vostri valori
questo aiuta ad avere delle persone che
soffrono conte lavorano con te vivono
con te come dice un importante filosofo
contemporaneo della scuola anglosassone
tony stark anche noto come iron man e io
quoto completamente i limiti sono fatti
per essere superati
e io vi dico superate lì e se ci
riuscite non salite sul punto più alto
del torrione ad agitarvi si può essere
ottimi e pessimi vincitori sfruttate i
vostri punti di forza e di debolezza
sfuggite agli stereotipi comunicate
apritevi con le persone tenete a bada la
parte arrogante del libris e invece
coltivate e fate liberare quella che
porta al miglioramento di voi e della
vostra vita
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]